some of Britain's fine art galleries
considered to be among the best in the
world are failing to pull in as many
people as they used to her living on
their doorsteps as overall attendances
saw the number of British visitors to
the National Gallery and the tape
galleries has dropped by twenty percent
in five years while joining us now are
the art critic I still love it and also
here Charles Samoa Smith who's the chief
executive of the Royal Academy of Arts
former director of both the national and
National Portrait Gallery's welcome to
you both while the locals going to these
estimable gallery Everett's intrigued by
this report because if you look at the
government report it's all good news
numbers are going up you have to analyze
the statistics very carefully and go
back five years and look at the numbers
five years ago which will Gompertz did
will compare two words with the BBC is
threat for the tape I don't know why
he's drawn attention to it I'll gather
when he asked the Gary's they were
unaware of it is true now I think it is
probably true I think you know there's a
boom in visitor numbers it's actually
quite expensive coming to London and I
think domestic tourism probably is a bit
down we found out at the academy we get
lots of friends who come very regularly
because they buy what's a subscription
but actually people are quite price
sensitive we've been in you know
people's payers not gone up and they're
making decisions as to whether or not
they come to London five times a year
for tempting I mean it's not one thing
that strikes me you're looking at those
numbers they jump around near two-year
surely it just depends on what kind of
exhibitions they only for example we had
that Matisse one at the Tate which drew
in record numbers isn't covered by those
figures so know when you've got a big
blockbuster exhibition you're going to
get the crowd in I blame a decline in
numbers on the fact that there's not
enough art in schools I think there
should be more art on the school
curriculum art should be encouraged you
know you don't go to an art gallery to
learn how to become a scientist or a
doctor or pilot or a mathematician but
in order to be creative and end up in
one of those professions artists help
you
it's like carbohydrate for the eyes of
vitamins for the soul you know it's
necessary as part of our daily life and
more people don't realize the merits of
going to an art gallery which is a shame
and it does come down to education I
mean your gallery did roll Academy it
puts on Big Show's and it charges for
them we do the point about the tape the
National Gallery's is that they're free
effectively to go into and and we are
told by the politicians one of the
reasons why their fries because they
want to encourage local people and
everyone to feel that they have access
to the National I think unfortunately
somebody at nash gary said it's because
we're an increasingly events based
culture and actually I was thinking
merged as I was coming here if I go to
New York I will go to museums and I'll
go to their permanent collections I'll
go to the Frick but in London I myself
at the weekend will go to exhibitions
more often than i will go to permanent
collections and I think days are
shifting balance towards if one's honest
exhibitions which are packaged where you
see something which has a narrative and
people know why they're going even
though they pay they don't necessarily
go to permanent collections in the way
they used to what's your reaction to
that because it does seem that you know
when you look at these museums the ones
that are covering these figures that all
the ones that don't charge so there's
any point for that I think we need to
alert people of the wonderful
collections we do have on our doorstep
that in essence do belong to us maybe
more of the marketing money has to be
spent less on the big blockbuster and
more of what's available every day of
the week I think that is correct because
in these institutions and run one of
them you can justify spending money on a
temporary exhibition because you coupe
it in the money you get at the cape
whereas in a national collection and I
worked in national collections you don't
advertise the fact you've got a puro on
the doorstep people will go to Italy in
order to go on the puro trail but they
forget that they can go on the periodic
trail in the National Gary and I think
we don't do nearly enough to communicate
that and yet the counter this is the
British Museum which seems to have no
problems with visit
is from either either category well
maybe that's more to do with again
school curriculum maybe being more child
friendly because it's to do with the
school curriculum but you know every
time you go into an art gallery it's
like walking onto a plot of soil and
your nourished you know you grow and
it's just just the most wonderful
magical experience and that's what we
need to get across and it's there every
day of the week not just in a
blockbuster I mean doesn't mean that it
up to galleries to put on more
activities that engage in particular
younger visitors I think all of all of
us are doing that a lot I think this
issue of encouragement in people to be
aware of what is on their doorstep I
think that thing that people you know
when they travel they get the guide and
they think what can I go to in Vienna or
if I go to Madrid I'll go to the Prado
and people forget that the VNA has an
unbelievable wealth of things and it's
going to me and all the wallace
collection or the soul music I mean
could it just be that I don't know
spanish or Italians or French people are
just more interested in painted art than
we are in this country no I think I
think a lot of it also has to do with
the fact that we we want to be
interactive with what's around us you
know okay well that's it you know so
perhaps you know we need and you know I
I hear people saying I won't go and sit
because I can google that work of art
but you don't get the same experience
you know you have a certain dialogue and
intimacy with the work of art it's like
falling in love all over again you
notices remember web complex has managed
to put a negative spin on what it's
essentially a very positive story
enormous bit numbers of people are going
to the tate in the National Gary it's
just that there's more more tourists
again and somewhat viewer I mean I don't
know what puts me off going to places
like the tape Mon is the number of the
crowds Jonas yep and take modern you
know people go as tourists it was it was
a new thing in two thousand and the
truth is that the way people work it's
they've been to take modern several
times and they don't necessarily go
again unfortunately I mean those are the
two biggest aren't they and
but if you look at the rest of the
numbers the others i've actually seen
attendance figures going up so yeah I
mean dad look not surprisingly at the
national portrait Gary when I was there
we did the marriott st no exhibition and
the numbers went up to 1.5 million and I
thought poor sandy Dan would never be
able in it would be unimaginable to ever
to be able to match that it would only
go down I was completely wrong it's gone
up and up and up and it's now two
million a year frankly when i was there
was I couldn't imagine two minutes yet
outside of long and we're also seeing
galleries and museums failing that's it
well the Whitworth in Manchester's just
reopened it to wonderful rave reviews
but we've come to sort of expect that we
need to be entertained we're a bit lazy
going to a gallery we go to a gallery in
it and expect to find a funfair there
sometimes it is and but you know we need
to put in some effort but there are
great rewards okay thank you